turns out the man most famous for
playing the wizarding world's nastiest
teacher was also a dedicated friend a
mentor and an enormous amount of fun to
be around who'd have guessed it Alan
Rickman might be gone but he left us a
lot to think about and a lot to take his
inspiration in January 2016 Rickman died
of pancreatic cancer at 69 he was no
spring chicken but he wasn't
particularly old either fans around the
world mourned the untimely nature of his
passing and it's seeming suddenness had
anyone known he was sick how long had he
been suffering and how severely had it
been publicized how could one beloved
man's passing in an age of such
unprecedented interconnectivity so
shocked the entire world simply put it
was a secret the first new thing the
world learned about Alan Rickman upon
his death was that he had been battling
pancreatic cancer for a few months prior
after being diagnosed in August
following a small stroke pancreatic
cancer sometimes called a silent cancer
takes time to present any symptoms and
is often found after a seemingly
unconnected problem surfaces Rickman
decided to keep the news confined to
close friends and family and soldiered
on with his work as it happened no one
knew what they were going to lose until
he was already gone
the Rickman portrayed many noteworthy
characters Severus Snape Harry Potter's
grouchy potions professor might be the
most memorable of all Snape is
vindictive Moody and even in his moments
of bravery deeply and unrelentingly
cynical it's a fine edge to dance upon
but Rickman made it look easy
for eight films he portrayed Snape with
caustic aplomb and that performance has
become nothing less than iconic that is
the second time you've spoken out of
turn Miss Granger are you incapable of
restraining yourself or do you take
pride in being an insufferable
know-it-all by all accounts it was also
the role that had least to do with his
actual personality when remembering the
actor posthumously colleagues and
friends have repeatedly touched upon his
unrelenting kindness and generosity of
spirit in a tribute for Entertainment
Weekly Kate Winslet mused if there was
one word I could use to really describe
Al it would be kind he was so kind
whenever L would go out to supper and
anyone else would try and pay he would
somehow have phoned ahead or slipped his
credit card ahead of the meal so no one
even got a look at the check
tales of helping hands thoughtful gifts
and general friendliness seemed to
surround Rickman's legacy he wasn't just
passively kind but actively generous
which is about as far from Snape as you
can get younger fans will never know how
heated the debate over Snape's true
loyalties grew back when the Harry
Potter saga was still a work in progress
Snape's motivations were murky and his
actions ambiguous until the very end
when it was finally revealed that he was
on the side of the angels all along
motivated by his deep and lasting love
for Harry's mother Lily though some had
guessed no one knew the full truth for
sure until the story's very final
chapters no one that is except Alan
Rickman it's since come to light that
author JK Rowling told to recommend the
truth about Snape's motivations years
earlier to help inform his performance
according to Rowling what she told him
boiled down to just one word if you
revisit the Potter films this knowledge
will become more readily apparent in
Rickman's performance although he is
sour unrelentingly harsh and sometimes
even outright cruel he returns over and
over again to the side of light and love
his anger at Harry appears so much more
nuanced than at first glance and his
frustration with the growing darkness
around him more pronounced Snape was
always much more than he seemed and
Rickman made that apparent in everything
from overt declarations of loyalty to
the subtlest most fleeting glances
though Rickman's trademark style and
double bass voice made every role he
took on memorable in its own right
arguably one of his best was Alexander
Dane in 1999's Galaxy Quest also an
actor the character of Dane feels
degraded by his role as dr. Lazarus on
the in universe Star Trek equivalent
Galaxy Quest which requires the use of a
complicated and silly looking skull
prosthetic as well as a horde of alien
catchphrases
by grabthar's hammer
[Music]
water savings Galaxy Quest became an
instant cult hit and is often hailed in
Star Trek fandom as a better Trek movie
than some of the official outings
Rickman's performance in particular of
course is held to be one of the film's
most memorable so it's probably no
surprise to find that a sequel was in
the works which was kept totally under
wraps until Rickman's tragic passing put
an end to the project it's a bittersweet
turn of events that access both the
testament to Rickman's acting and a sad
reminder of what could have been there
are few relationships in the Harry
Potter series more charged and complex
than the one between Harry and Snape
after all Harry Potter and the
half-blood Prince pretty much translates
as Harry Potter and Severus Snape Snape
basically gives his life to protect
Harry yet bullies him relentlessly for
years meanwhile Harry loathes Snape to
the point of obsession yet ends up
naming his son after him the
relationship sits at the heart of the
series and the crux of Harry's journey
it's only appropriate then that Alan
Rickman matters so deeply to Daniel
Radcliffe in a Facebook post made after
Rickman's death Radcliffe hailed him as
one of the greatest actors he would ever
work with he continued he is also one of
the loyalists and most supportive people
I've ever met in the film industry
Radcliffe went on to detail Rickman's
kindness and generosity his mastery of
the craft of acting and his wit adding
one particularly heart-wrenching detail
I'm pretty sure he came and saw
everything I ever did on stage both in
London and New York
Rickman's dedication to performance was
legendary but it was easily surpassed by
his devotion to his fellow performers
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]